I'm tremendously excited to see the new
season yeah I have a million questions
and I'm never going to get through them
all right let's let's go for it here we
go how did you decide or how was it
decided that you would do episodes
direct episodes one seven and eight
um I mean I I knew I was going to come
in and I wanted to direct episodes this
season but I was also playing this role
as an executive producer this year with
with John and and Dave and so I really
wanted to you know as someone who's been
around since season one how how do I
best sort of set the tone for what we're
doing this season
um and express that in a way to the ex
directors that are coming in that might
be new to the process and so it felt uh
right that the first one happened and
and then obviously to to conclude the
season storytelling with seven and eight
um so to have those bookends both gave
me an anchor in the season as a as a
director and into the the real details
of of that work
um and where we've been and where we're
going uh so I felt like having you know
sort of being both the the lead off leg
and the the anchor of the of the uh of
the relay felt like the the right place
to be creatively just because it could
give me a context of everything we were
doing and and also helped to express
that both the cast crew and and the
directors as they were coming aboard
will fans at the end of the season after
your episode eight will they be
screaming at the television that they
have to wait a while for season four or
will they be like okay I mean it's
interesting because I I think what we've
been doing with the storytelling in the
first two seasons and then with book of
Boba Fett has has led us to this point
so I think on on one level there is a
sense of things coming together a
culmination nation of stories that have
been built for a very long time but I
also think there are seeds that are
going to get planted throughout the
season that that point uh point the way
forward in terms of where the story
could continue to go and so
um so I I think you know if we're doing
what we're doing well it's a little bit
of both but I do think
um there there's something at least for
me that feels like we we've we've we've
reached a a kind of a chapter and we
where we're ending a chapter uh in the
storytelling by by the end of season
three that's been built since we first
met these two characters
um the first season so uh so I do think
it's a little bit more of that even
though I think yeah you'll I hope you're
still screaming at the TV about what
where we're going next one of the things
though this is a third season and I was
saying off camera to you the first
season you're learning how to make the
show second season you're finding the
volume technology
etc etc what have you been able to do in
season three that perhaps you couldn't
have done in the previous Seasons uh
using the technology and storytelling
yeah I think you know even though the
technology there hasn't been a big
breakthrough in the way that the volume
and stagecraft was that first season
what we have is a group of storytellers
filmmakers actors that have been
involved with the storytelling of
mandalorians in season one so it really
feels like a
um a team that's been together for a few
seasons and has has and now playing well
together sort of understand uh what
they're doing we know where everybody is
on the court on the pitch on the field
you know and so it feels it really does
feel like we can push things creatively
in ways that we wouldn't have attempted
to season one and and we're doing things
now just in term terms of the just the
scale of things we're doing with the
volume
how the you know the process of sort of
building and the and the and the the
sort of the the
realistic way that they're starting to
be rendered and this season has been has
just you know been fascinating to me uh
and and then also in some ways when when
you're pushing things you're you're
breaking it too and so I think we're
still breaking we're still breaking the
volume and still breaking the technology
but it's because we're I think in a very
confident place about what we're doing
um but I think you know season three
again is is both in Scott in size and in
ambition uh the biggest one yet thank
you so much for your time